optimism is different from blind
positivity
blind positivity which a lot of leaders
think they have to have all the time
they think if they're positive then
it'll make people feel better about the
situation and no matter how difficult or
complex or dark times get
these leaders come to work and say
everything is good everything's fine
we're gonna be okay everything's good
and it actually backfires
it make things worse because if I'm
struggling and I'm confused and I feel
tension and I see my leader always
positive I think there's something wrong
with me it makes it worse
this is not optimism
optimism is the undying belief that the
future is bright
but it's realistic it can accept that
the times we are in now can be dark we
are in a dark tunnel right now
I don't know how long we're going to be
in this tunnel and it's going to be
difficult but I know one thing for sure
that if we work together and take care
of each other
we will get through this and we will
come out stronger than we went in that's
optimism it's the undying belief that
the future is bright and the only way to
get through darknesses together and I
think any business leader worth any
value today has to embody optimism but
again it accepts the reality of
difficult times now and looks to the
bright future